ladies and gentlemen it is Monday and uh
I got a question man yeah sure buddy I
got a big question you go ahead why in
the [__] did anybody bring me a cabber
egg you didn't get you didn't get a
cabber egg not one damn it's the first
Easter I've never had one bro my kids
ate so much sugar and so many chocolate
eggs it's Easter that they started to
wig out they started to wig out toward
the end of the day did anyone bring
crying falling down the ground did any
did you guys have catberry eggs I
haven't even seen one I didn't see one
goddamn catberry egg world is going on I
did not see one my girl's mom brought me
just a large chocolate bunny which I ate
last night yeah I I ears first never
asked first y my son ate the ears off
his bunny this morning say a lot I was
like you got to eat some breakfast and
he was like what I'm just eating the the
ears oh wait was it solid or uh Hollow
it was Hollow I love the hollow ones the
H are I know I know I know the rich like
The the thickness of the solid one not
me man I'm all straight I like a hollow
rabbit there's like a there's like a
reward to a Hol rabbit it's easier to
eat or something you don't feel like
you're feels nice that the other one
it's like biting into marble almost I
know exactly what you mean but yeah not
one [__] cry egg man super I I ran so
far in the morning because I figured I
was going to eat Carberry eggs I'm on a
clear broth diet right now and and
you're making me hungry clear broth why
for how long well I got I'm at 6:45 a.m.
they're going to stick a camera up my
[__] take a look at my rump hole it's
just like a little like it's just one of
those little spy I asked for a larger
camera yeah yeah you want like you want
a MAG light up there a MAG completely
unnecessary sir at nah put a bazooka up
there I want a MAG just take your fist
and put you know what put a GoPro on
your fist and just fist up no anesthetic
shove it up there I uh why wait why are
you doing it's the 50-year-old checkup
you got to do it at 50 everyone does
it's everybody well because they because
Colin cancer I guess is the most one of
the most curable cancers if you catch it
early and it's the it's also I think one
of the more common so at 50 they go
we're going to stick a camera up your
ass and look at your ass that's how it
is they're looking at your prostate they
look at your colon so your colon is a
long find out how long a colon is oh
they're they got a snake up there and
they got to see if there's any kind of
abnormality like that video game Snake
just like so I got to keep so I got to
have my my [__] got to be super
clean yeah it can't it can't be Andy
defrain through that [__] [__] to
be let me explain something like a slip
and slide I got a here's it's about 5et
all right 5T that's as tall as AR now
here's the thing so that camera is going
to go from the top the bottom of her
shoe to the top of her head they got to
look at in your body that's right and
it's just a little camera with a light
on like a little like and they're
looking for you know uh KN knobs you
know things that look out of the
ordinary and they can cut it out if
there's you know a situation but um you
want to get it in time and that means I
may or may not have already taken
lative are you supposed to take laxitive
yeah and then I got at 6:00 p.m. I got
to drink this solution that really
cleans me out is it's Miralax oh yeah
yeah yeah you got to drink that [__]
down you're going be pissing out of your
ass I'm excited about that you're just
going to clean you out though probably
going to lose some weight probably I'll
be clean I'm pretty clean they check
your they check your prostate while
they're back there they kind of melt
that that's with checkups where they got
to see if it's flat if it's enlarg then
there's a problem sometimes and so was
your doctor like a week go like yeah
it's that 50 checkup yes well I went
when I was 49 this same doctor and he
goes you uh you know I I insurance won't
cover until you're 50 so I can write you
know you got to see I mean I can are you
having any abnormalities I are no no
nothing you but I'm a hyper contract
dude you're so worried about everything
you get a bump oh my God I'm I love this
you're like I'm lactose intolerant and
you do a test like you're not you're not
you're I'm so happy oh my God wine keeps
me up at night like what the [__] is
going on right now no it's not I'm a
[__] about stuff plus I had I you know
had that food poisoning a little bit
mild and I've been like a little queasy
for the whole week and I've been like
something's wrong with me I'm going to
die something's wrong so it's good for
you get checked up just so you can check
that off look man this whole week I got
checkup I got I got callon stuff I got
invisaline I got to fix after we get
back I got [__] to do line I am too on
the bottom of my teeth why it's been we
talked I don't like my SN haon add
something else to the list that you're
complaining about which really isn't
that bad add something else to the list
you have to get tattoo you [__] Mor
bro what are we gonna get and when and
who I got to yes I do and I'm getting
you know you cannot back out I'm getting
a tattoo I've already I've already I
know that so here's the question you
accepted it I've accepted it I think I
think you're telling the truth cuz your
wife even T what do you think BR get for
a tattoo I'm getting it I'm not going to
back out I said I was so here's the
thing I'm going to get a tattoo of my
colon no I'm going to get a tattoo of I
mean what's a good tattoo do people are
saying ideas I are you know that Joe
Romero is coming up with some ideas I
think it has something to do I think it
has to do something with Abbot Kenny
maybe you know yeah maybe M on your back
hey bro not a mural giant Venice canel
mer on your back no no dude I don't want
that with me holding up like 10 Mill no
no I don't want you on the on the my I
can't have you on my back can't what do
you think I should do I don't know man
you're the [__] tattoo guy bro kind
of do I get a uh I'll get I mean I have
a bunch of angels you could have an
angel holding up a 10 sign like like
Wilt Chamberlain when he scored 100
points will make it old school it's like
an angel holding up a 10 that's not bad
or maybe just abini fight club something
with the logo or is that I don't know if
you'd want Fight Club on your body yeah
but I'm a fighter maybe just like Kenny
you know I could do it with you yeah how
about how about how about I got heavy
hands or no you know what you should get
what would you hate me so much if I came
back I head that be terrible I just had
boxing and I had boxing cloes dude what
if you got uh just like old school like
that giant mega Mother Ship of a missile
you get a bunch of missiles like going
down your arm and then it ends here and
you go cuz I Dro bombs oh [__] that how
annoying that I had a buddy who was
boxing you know he did Golden Gloves I
don't know if he won or not and then he
was going to go pro he could he always
said he could beat Manny Pacquiao and he
got a tattoo I mean you know pretty new
to it he got straight like boxing gloves
tanging off his you got to be [__]
kidding bro come on man muhamad Ali
proba unless it's your life bro and even
then it's a little much even then you're
get made fun of yeah even then it's a
little much even then's a
doozy um I had a funny experience I was
at Frank Row's for Easter he bought this
new sick Crib in uh I say crib now yeah
I don't say I'm Street down street uh he
had this he had this bombass crib he oh
man he has a bombass crib dope crib yeah
this dope as dope God when you say dope
it hurts my heart yo when you say dope
an angel Dan bro dope as [__] there's
one and and uh I met his dad and his mom
he comes from a big Italian family from
New York from the Bronx yeah and and I
interrupted a
story classic Callum yep Dean his
brother who I love Dean gillo was was
telling not his brother his cousin was
telling a story and I thought it was
done he stopped it's a long story about
how they got in a fight and I wanted to
tell a story of I was going to make up a
story yeah and I go you know what
happened to me and Dean goes and Frank
goes he wasn't done and they all had an
overreaction like they because they're
Italian they just F he's not what the
[__] is with this guy and all of a
sudden I just his his 75-year-old dad
starts going
Bo and I was I didn't know what was
going on at first and I went huh and
he's got his hands he's making like a a
a you know like a funnel with his hands
going
boo boo and he starts walking towards me
and he grabs him by the chest and pushes
me against the wall and goes boo keep
going I got him over here keep going
he's F that gu here to control you and
me [__] hilarious exactly I was
laughing so hard he was just like Boo
then I say something to my wife and he
grabs me goes hey you don't ever talk to
her like that again in fact come over
here track me goes apologize to I go his
name is pasal I pasal Mr Mr pasal Mr
Gill I apologize he goes don't apologize
to me apologize to the woman my wife is
like what I go I'm really sorry when I
talk to you that way was I was ly he
goes now get back over there that's what
he did to me the whole [__] night I
love it what a great so that's what you
guys did on Easter yeah you guys do an
Easter egg hunt yeah Easter egg hunt the
whole [__] thing I feel like Easter
especially now the Easter baskets like
you don't have to just get kids
chocolate like
uh my girls friends her family my family
didn't send [__] way to go Denver um way
to go guys um no one sense sh I got
about this anyways uh I feel like kids
now it's changing you know like we're
not very religious family you know like
I sent Brian and Chris dilia text that
said Jesus
saves Sunday that was so funny dilia Tes
back hey man I kept respond back Jesus
sa J finally you're like Jesus saves you
[__] I'm like
but I get a bunch of those texts like
okay all right um I feel like Easter's
changing where you can get it's just a
it's almost like a birthday or Christmas
like you can just get the kid anything
yeah like you can just do whatever you
get him like he got a train set he got
some [__] clothes like it just
doesn't money it doesn't have to be
about chocolate did you dye eggs you're
too young he's Too Young Too Young we
had we had colored eggs and we um hit my
my wife set up the whole dying egg thing
it's a beast it's a beast At first she
went and bought a bunch of brown eggs
and boil them she was like cuz she was
just so distracted and she goes I just
hear her go what the [__] I go whoa what
happened she go I died a bunch of brown
eggs I'm ah I go well can you paint them
she goes no I can't [__] paint him
runs out and goes buys a bunch of white
eggs and apparently what you have to
realize about kids is that when they're
doing something it's the whole world
right everything so she my daughter's
trying to dye her egg she's a
perfectionist trying to dye her egg no
white egg a certain kind of yellow it
gets screwed
up tears now I as a father go what what
are you doing what's a big deal please
relax my wife who knows better realizes
that my daughter that was that was her
project that was her life a magenta
color yeah it was a big deal because
she'd done all the right steps and it
didn't work out and that's the kind of
[__] you can fight about as a parent
when you're not on the same page with as
a parent and you have different
philosophies about how to raise a child
that can lead to some tension we had to
see a professional about that did you
and the professional just wanted to get
you guys on the same page professional
was very interesting but see I think
it's good to have a SPL I mean last you
guys have to be on the same page and not
argue in front of uh the kiddos but I
think it's good to come from both
aspects I have a splash of Brian splash
of Amanda you can't argue in front the
kid about it yeah it's how that that
kids watch more of what you do not what
you say yep so you better set an example
of how you fight you can complain you
can fight but don't call each other
names all that stuff but what's
interesting is that I have a different
point of view on how to raise a child so
Maya is little old school which is the
idea that the world's are kicking the
nuts so sometimes I'm like hey stop the
[__] we're doing this yeah I don't
care about your feelings and stuff like
that well I mean yeah I hear you but you
know you can't allow your irritation
sometimes to color what the best
approach would be there there's a there
are different ways to approach things
with children it doesn't mean you're not
Stern doesn't mean there's not
discipline in the household but a lot of
the [__] is counterintuitive to me but
what I was trying to say to this woman
was what what I realized was that like
in life in general I don't really want
to win this I don't care about my I
don't know how to parent I'm learning
how to do this it's about the best way
it's about the best [__] way right
it's like if somebody says you're
kicking wrong you're not going to be
like no this is the way I do it cuz I
want to be right you're going to go all
right what I do turn my hip more I'm
doing this wrong whatever it might be I
mean that's that's a good way to be so I
learned
no I don't think there's there's no
winning or losing it's just the losing
is if you raise a [__] up kid they
lost but I know parents who they won't
even let you touch their kid CU they
worry about germs or something or they
won't let their kids see Coke cans or
they won't let them be around other kids
who are aggressive or they think
everyone uh because their kid has nut
allergies that uh or they're allergic to
something that you can't have any nut
there's no almond butter anything for
all the kids which I don't agree with it
but if that's the way you want to raise
your kid I'm going to tell you
my not going to put up but so so here's
the thing that and she comes in when a
when one one parent has that philosophy
and the other parent has your philosophy
well that's something you guys should
have went over before you you don't
sometimes you don't know until you're
raising a human being together right so
sometimes you guys should know now
though yeah well well we're kind of like
being pissed that you found out your
Tesla's electric no because there are
sign no no because there are problems
that that arise when you when your child
has a problem that you're trying to deal
with it from two different perspectives
if it's a problem that yeah I see see
what saying yeah we don't have to get in
detail I know what you're saying yeah
and so so so you know and and and what
your culture is like how you grew up all
that [__] plays a factor into it D I'll
tell you what's weird is like Joe she
grew up you know obviously strict
Mexican Catholic Family super strict
with tiger I thought I would be strict I
think when it comes to like School
athletics whatever he wants to do
entertainment I'll be strict I can lead
him towards that road but when it comes
to other stuff I don't have it in me I'm
I'm not a pushover but like Joe will
yell him and spank him if he comes
running towards me yeah like I love it
I'm like hell yeah let's get out well
because or Jo will slap him and he'll
you know he'll look at me yeah I'm like
yeah that was [__] up and so slapping
and yelling is is in the new way of
looking at things I'm not saying it's
right or wrong but that would be
considered they they they they would
tell you that they better they tell you
get on their level and talk to them no
no they don't no not at all actually but
they would say that there are better
ways to do that
because they're they we we you get into
it see here's the thing with kids that I
also didn't know is that there is a
separation between sort of the rational
brain The Reptilian Brain when they're
when they're when they're over when
they're hyper stimulated and one of the
things you're going to you're going to
deal with like all parents deal with is
that your kid is going to have his own
idea of how to do [__] and 75% of kids
she said no matter what it's just how
human beings are I was like I I want to
teach so so she said a lot of parents
will teach will parent and a lot of
times they'll parent their child in a
way that is the way they didn't get
parents so so they're trying to make up
for a deficit that they didn't get if
you have shitty parents make sense no
it's not shitty parents sometimes your
parents are busy is a deficit but but
some parents are like um so for examp w
present or they were busy yeah or or
they no no no or they just didn't they
they parented a different way so example
for example um maybe your parents love
the [__] out of you they were always
there but they never really taught you
things because they didn't know how to
like so for example they didn't teach
you how to approach a sport the right
way or practice whatever it might be
what we do is we try to fill in that
deficit no parents perfect there's going
to be deficits in how you're raised and
you're going to try to fill in that
deficit but one of the things that I
notic about child psychology which I
didn't realize is kid freaks out
screaming and yelling a lot of parents
will yell that down they'll match that
yelling right they'll be like hey enough
of that [__] stop it right now or
they'll spank the kid problem is that
kid when he's there there is a
separation between his rational brain
and his Reptilian Brain he's gone
they're not that kid is not hearing back
so what you'll what they'll do is
they'll like a lot of times the better
way to do it is to either if he's saying
bad things you stare at that kid you can
leave or you can you can basically not
engage wait till the kid calms down and
then come back and administer your
lesson which is something that I never
thought about but it it's [__]
effective because with kids 75% of those
kids they don't want their parents
teaching them anything it's a weird
thing that that a lot of they don't know
if it's evolutionary but you will get
resistance and they they're teach can
teach them all day but you may have a
great way to teach them and they're like
I don't want to hear it I don't want to
know my my teach I think it just depends
too I think everyone has I would have
some you know I'd have some words with
that lady you know I don't agree with
everything I think it just depends too
it just dep it also depends on your kid
man sometimes your kid has [__] up
issues maybe has attention issues maybe
maybe you know there's a lot of things
that go into it but there's not one
right answer like her ways not might not
work for my kid you know what I'm saying
it just depends yeah well one thing is I
don't know much about it and I don't
know a lot about child psychology and
there are people that can definitely
help like for me anyway like where I
there people can help the I I'm also at
a super Advantage because I had a beast
of a dad yeah I had a beast of a dad
lead by example you know what I'm saying
like there's a you'll you'll have your
own issues like every parent everyone
does yeah everyone does there is
challenges I I just think it's the same
it goes back to the same thing I'm not
hating that that's great for you be I
think it's great but I think there's
this new wave of people where do this to
the kid don't talk to them like this and
make sure you're on the same level and
treat them like a little human I'm like
like what the [__] you talking about
since when what are you talking about
and pay me this much money I'm going to
show you how to what are you talking
that's been my problem is what are you
[__] talking I don't trust New Age
thinking there's a lot of new psychology
it goes the same with with the working
out oh you do this now oh well what's
what's wrong with the meat and potatoes
we've been doing forever you're just
trying to put a different spin out
that's what I brought up in the rum as I
said I said look I appreciate this
there's a lot I can learn here you know
you're you sure she's been doing for a
time got it great kids her kids turn out
amazing I got it it's all good however
there is also history and there's also
the way things have been done and you
know at the end of the day I know a lot
of parents that were really strict not
so strict some parents hit their kids
the people that come out of those those
parents are not all screwed up I mean a
lot lot of like a lot of people that I
know actually who are really high
functioning adults who are really
interesting that I really like being
around had some trauma in their
childhood had parents that were really
strict maybe even got hit they were old
school and you know what uh like the the
way like old school Catholic kids were
raised you got spanked hit I'm
openminded but I'm also saying let's not
reinvent the we you go that's how I feel
that's where that's where all this
psychology gets confusing man cuz you
can get you can go down that rabbit hole
how many people you know who go who've
been in therapy for 25 years and they're
a bigger mess than when they started
like well I I know I know people you
know I go to this uh Park here by where
I live and you know it's a upper you
know class Park and you talk to the
parents and like well my kid does this
this this I'm like he's two men then
he's with the nanny when are you present
right there's your [__] problem y
you're never pres they call affluenza
you're the nanny's dealing with them or
this teacher's dealing with them or he's
doing this just so you can do what shop
what the [__] are you talking about well
you know they they just on NPR they had
this woman who wrote a book about how
children are dealing with anxiety
getting ulcers uh all kinds of
depression because their days they can
be in elementary school and their days
if you look at Homework school and
activities they're doing they're putting
70 hours in a week you got to be a kid
man you got to be a kid and play man you
got be kid and the parents have to don't
just put it off on someone else well you
were saying also don't these kids are
specializing in sports that's a terrible
idea right terrible idea cuz the parents
want the next LeBron James LeBron James
didn't just play basketball but now they
the parents see money how big of a you
know Money Maker it is and that they
want to give their kids the best chance
for a scholarship then they should play
All Sports and matter of fact most
Scouts um college coaches professional
coaches they want a more diverse athlete
than just specialize in one thing yeah
also the kids can get burnt out yeah and
I also think you learn about all that
[__] from doing from doing things right
yeah you just want to be welled team
sports all that [__] a bad idea dude
I'll tell you what [__] me up two
things this weekend we'll start with
this one and I might [__] up your
current event and I'm not sure probably
well but uh have you seen that the Ser
serial killer in Ohio driving around
killing people on Facebook live no I
can't watch it he killed an older man
right dude so I'm like what the [__]
it's going to be easy to catch this dude
we have to makeing Mal's car we know
where he works he he gave his
name he literally he's like my name's
Mike whatever what the [__] Kevin I
forget what it is he drove by a shot a
guy no walked up to him cuz his girl
broke up so he's on Facebook live and
he's like you know man I'm always the
butt of the joke like he doesn't seem
too crazy just seems like a piece of
[__] and I hope they shoot him in the
[__] face guys like that don't need
to be on this Earth I don't give a [__]
what you say so he's Facebook live he's
like you know man I've just I've always
been the butt of jokes and people making
fun of me and um you know I I help all
these other people no one helps me I'm
just sick of this [__] man then my girl
broke up with me and you know I'm just
I'm just sick of it and finally I just
[__] flipped man and he's like I'm
going to kill innocent people just to
just for the [__] of it cuz I'm sick of
this [__] and he goes and just let you
know I've killed probably 16 people
total they can't confirm that they think
he's lying he's just this fat piece of
[__] I get so upset about it so uh he
was like I've killed uh these homeless
people in this place here and he's
giving adress stuff like that no one can
confirm the kills though so they think
he's makeing it up but then he's like
you know what watch this he hits over
it's just some I don't know 78 year old
80y old dude and he's like what's up man
and he's like tell me your name he tells
him his name and I went down this rabbit
hole saw the real video [__] my Easter
up Eastern night take [__] so then the
dude's like my name's whatever and he's
like H he's like 78 he's like um uh
something uh shann and something this is
what happens because you did this to me
just shoots him in the head in the head
in the head and then and he's like this
motherfucker's dead see Shan this what
you get that you cause this gets back in
the car he's like I'm just s this man
I'm going to keep doing it until I get
caught and hopefully I kill enough so
they give me life in prison I'm like God
hope
they shoot you in your [__] gut and
your titties or torture you hopefully
the homies get a hold of you and just
torture you that's what should happen
people like that shouldn't have a trial
and keep doing all this I'm so sick of
that [__] oh he's mentally ill well he's
he's stable enough to get on Facebook
live do this not be caught all this [__]
oh he's mental he's a piece of [__] we
got to [__] kill this guy he's an
[__] so I went down that rabbit hole
cuz I saw that I think his name's Kevin
Smith I'm not sure I think might be
Kevin Smith Smith I don't well no that's
well that's a fighter Brian yeah yeah
easy I'm pretty sure it's Kevin Smith so
he um does that right and so I get and I
see the video I'm like God damn it
[__] up my day anyways oh let me watch
this Anthony Casey or Casey Anthony uh
documentary yeah that was on uh TLC
that's him there that's that fat piece
of [__] Ste stev Steve Stevens I know
some [__] like that anyways you know
the Casey Anthony story you remember
that trial the hot mom who killed her
daughter then got dude I I I don't know
what I was doing was it seven years ago
I I missed all of it I don't maybe I was
fighting balls deep and something I
really didn't see so it's all new to
me this again just a terrible person man
this documentary you're watching it and
you know they found the little girl [__]
30 30 days later they reported missing
they the night she went missing they
show her at this club dancing
promiscuous having fun 2 days later even
though her daughter's missed she get a
tattoo that says say the good life in
Italian on her back then they find out
that her boyfriend they they uh they
were drug dealers for Xanax so she would
constantly give the little girl Xanax to
keep her asleep so she go out and party
and stuff Jesus piece of [__] so then
they find the body whatever 30 40 days
later she's in prison at this time in
jail you know going getting ready to go
on trial and the parents go you know
they found the body it was your daughter
she goes of course didn't give a [__]
was like yeah what can you of course and
then you know she had this close
relationship with her father and she's
like Dad I just want you to know all
this isn't because you and your mom all
this stuff and then on trial they find
out she's sleeping with her attorney
that's how she's paying the bills
because he's the same attorney that got
um uh in Hernandez off helped with OJ
like he's a piece of [__] so she's
sleeping with him can't pay the bill
she's giving him sexual her got we'll
get about we'll get to that this is
another story so she's sleeping with him
to pay the
bills then it comes out to a total spin
the reason why she's [__] up she said
she was sexually molested by her Father
which isn't some great dad like no
that's true she kept bringing that up
and eventually they just backed off CU
like we have no proof there's nothing
there the dad was so distraught about
his granddau grandaughter dying and that
his daughter flipped on him and said he
was sexual he tries committing suicide
oh my God it's just some heavy [__] so
all this [__] adds up you it's 110% her
she's the most hated person in America
this [__] gets off because they're like
we can't prove that she actually did it
because the body was just Bones by the
time they found it and they don't know
if she drowned or what but they they're
saying that she's not we can't put her
away for life or give her a death
penalty because we can't 100% confirm
that the body even though they found
duct tape over the mouth and it was
confirmed she would give her a Xanax and
stuff so they un so they let her off so
wasn't her dad a suspect for for a while
they said they thought her dad helped
her it was her idea but that got thrown
out it was just [__] wow so then
this gets over I'm like godamn damn it
what a terrible Easter but I got to find
out what this [__] is up to so I got to
find out it says Casey Anthony now this
[__] is in Florida lives with the
attorney that helped her works for him
lives with him it's it's rumored that
she's pregnant and getting married she
tried start her own photography clinic
but she what she started a social media
like you know like hey whatever Casey
Anthony photography didn't she
CH her name I don't know but Society
picked that [__] up real fast and went
oh huh and she got so many negative
comments she had to get out of that so
they're saying she has no friends she
like what are you going to do killed a
[__] 2-year-old God it's some dark sh
mainly you went out and we're fine fine
she flourishing getting the good life
just a piece of sh so knew that that
child was no longer an anchor for her
how terrible is that man terrible is
that sociopaths and and goodlooking girl
too have you seen her good her eyes are
as blue as the
she's a pretty girl just a piece of [__]
you see what we're working I've seen her
face but I have not you know let me see
what's
what go to the far right one uh third
one down one more down third third row
bottom right yes that's the picture that
most people remember as yeah very pretty
she was in a [__] K she looks pretty
yeah she was in a killer I'd bust on her
stupid face hey man okay but can you not
say that because you don't if she wasn't
a killer you would bust on her face
that's what I'm saying but if you said
if she wasn't a killer I'd bust on her
stupid face so you're already assuming
she's stupid and you'd still want to
bust on her face if she wasn't a killer
which would kind of mean she's a good
person but you just called her stupid
you called the Casey Anthony that isn't
bad well look at her there with with
bring titties I got to looks like she
got just mentioned D I'm just watch I'm
just looking at this to make sure
everything is okay po taste Casey
Anthony with [__] I'll be honest with
you it's a little hot as well I'm going
to be honest with you you might be a
killer but we do shows in Florida let's
say we're down in Florida we're at a bar
and she's like whoa firing the kid yeah
fellas listen yeah and let's say we're
both singing at the time she goes yeah I
don't know what you heard but here's
what really happened and then shows this
video she goes you twoo mind running a
train on me in the back here yeah and
can I film it and I'd be like we'll call
it all right but I don't approve I don't
approve you as a person or what you do
yeah I would say we're down to do it we
getting duct tape it's about to get it's
about to get aggressive is isn't Louis
CK the guy who said if I'm having sex if
I'm about to have an orgasm you could be
cutting my mother's head off in front of
me and I'd be like when I'm done we're
going to talk about this [__] that's
hilarious yeah I don't know with I've
always said what would you do though I
mean I'd be like what if she what if
what do you found out after the fact I
would be like no way I'm not doing that
here where where people can see me leave
with you now here's the thing I would do
this I I'd be like oh yeah that sounds
amazing oh oh you like the older guy oh
you oh you want to take you want to take
the kid for spin no problem you guys
have Fone I won't say a word real quick
picture for just personal reasons here
click I'm like have a good time guys you
want me to get the Uber I'll get you
guys an Uber and then as soon the next
morning I'd post Brian [__] Casey
Anthony well let me ask you this in
personal question and I know the answer
sometimes men are [__] we're we're
crazy because if we we got a a a dime
piece in our sights and we think it's
going to happen that girl could be a
straightup racist she could be a
straight up bad person retile brain
kicks in my dick goes I'll figure it out
later I've had girls say some [__] where
I've been like you are an absolutely
terrible [__] person I hate
everything about you so hot is my dick I
so hot my but I dick do I'm going to
gift you my peace my dick your dick goes
n we'll figure it out man come on and
you know I had a couple jokes she's just
joking man let's feel it out look at the
lips oh it's terrible it is weird man
it's terrible she's a piece of [__] her
and that other guy hopefully they catch
that killer in Ohio for sure I want to
go out of the house for a little bit cuz
just randomly killing people there like
five states on on lockdown right now
they always say that war and Chaos
brings out a bunch of those people
they're all in the Woodwork they're all
waiting this guy is just his girl
breaking up with him she just flips out
but I think what else is fascinating not
fascinating but he's he killed that
older man right who can't fight back cuz
he's this fat out of pieace obviously
undisciplined piece of [__] so if he get
catches like a young strapping dude
who's like what the [__] and he's like
no what the [__] and beats his ass be
glorious it would be my thing is is if
you're an Ohio resident he drive let's
say I'm in Ohio right I'm going to get
coffee he he drives up to me he's like
yo man what's going on and I'm like oh
that's him and I'm like pretend it's not
he I knocked the gun out and then I'm
just like check this out Facebook
live douche pancake yep Ohio pancake yep
do we celebrate and I get a key to the
city or am I doing some years Casey
Anthony style uh I think you you
celebrate you get a key to the city you
think they're like we get it bro you
took seral kill first of all I thought
he was the minute you see a guy like
that and if you attacked him and killed
him and you should kill him with your
bare hands uh you you could be like I
thought he was going to kill me well
I've seen his Facebook live videos I
thought he was going to kill me you get
off on that what would you do would you
just choke him to death I would punch
him Square in the face as hard as I can
and then I mount him on top and then
just rain these elbows down into his
face turned into elbow you'd elbow kill
him [__] Hawaiian shaved eyes really
yes you just keep you keep driving that
elbow in this is going to break just can
just keep on keeping on so that you just
keep on keeping on just B wear wearing
his face just go then I then while he's
there I'd have you filming this you'd be
with me I'd take out my piece and I'd
have a hard piss lined up cuz I drank a
bunch of coconut water and I'd piss on
that flat panc be going wi sh Hardon
nope and then we both go oh hi oh oh hi
oh why well it's the CH they do Ohio
State okay sorry oh no I just want to
say no we won't be heroes I know but I
just want to go piss Brandon you can do
hard you can do that first but but then
we got to go into the chance okay oh hi
all right cuz you really got to you
really got to [__] stick at home man
you got to make him feel like a piece of
[__] he's kind of dead by that point
yeah I know but his family and friends
need to see that or he's all maimed
up or he's got he's real he's real all
kinds of maimed up or I mean if you try
well this might it's too much we we've
already gotten pretty deep I was going
to say or I just choke him out and you
know it's not gay but you mean we feel
must run and train on them yeah not he's
not my type no no not you know not
getting it up it would be weird if you
had no problem getting it up and I'd be
like it's for Ohio it's for the state of
Ohio I'm doing it I'm doing it for the
state I know but your dick is rock hard
it's literally took some drugs it's
Diamond hard I I didn't see you taking
any drugs you're clearly TR go up the
street did the Jon Jones little sippy I
don't know still how your Rod is getting
that hard now it's not running train
it'd be a caboose I'm in the front
you're in the back my dick is turtle
head you're in the back on his big fat
ass nope I'm sure not I can't do it BR
no you're 50 I can't get it up bro I I'm
going to give you some of the juice I
won't work it doesn't matter how much I
could be popping Viagra like Tic Tacs no
dude your dick is so hard you've got to
do something about that dong we'll
figure it out and then all the just the
love and admiration you get from the
city of Ohio you get your pick not if
you
have LeBron not if you're buggering his
but if they see you banging his ass
they're going to be like did nobody's
going to be like he's a hero Ur Meer is
going to be like he CH him
unconscious you know what it's going to
happen you be the Vince Bali of Ohio
State they're going to have you come out
run a route it's going be great you're
have your jersey say the kid on the back
no because I understand that but not
he's he's out on his stomach and he's
out let me just go through the you've
got to get his pants down you have to
spread those then you got to get your
piece all like then and then you have to
kind of lie down on him you know cuz
that's the only way to he's lying there
I'm doing for the city of you got to
reach down and peel his rump open for
Cleveland well dude no Cleveland doesn't
want you to to bang him on the sidewalk
like that damn when he say bang that's
well that's what it is sir it's not it's
it is it's not you're not doing
superheroes no we're
not it's one thing to choke a guy
unconscious it's another thing to
actually then see that's not enough for
human like that that's not enough that's
not enough well just kill him maybe no
that's too easy that's an easy way out
yeah but he might come to and be like oo
no no no you look at this guy he's gu
look at him
yeah he's got a beard I could we don't
know where he is five states on alert
after alleged Facebook killer promised
more deaths I mean he looks like he'd be
pretty easy to find 6'1 244 PBS with a
terrible
beard evil um did you see the fights
Brendan shop I did yeah I did Brian
congrats out there to Mr Robert Whitaker
to start oh my God I had to I wow I had
to even issue a not an apology but I
just admitted I was wrong I love that
whenever you picked like oh you're so
off man like yeah no I did not pick the
underdog Whitaker to annihilate Jack Ray
Jo I literally had to go on Twitter and
Instagram like I did not call that one
man holy [__] the Whitaker is the real
deal that happens man until you see them
cuz name the best guy who's beat Brunson
who ran straight forward at him right
until that fight we really haven't seen
him fight the Upp line he looked like
his I mean he was he was kicking I mean
he knocked him out with a kick then a
punch but um he his hands were low and
he looked like he's had a lot of boxing
obviously that's how he fights man right
yeah you don't I love I love that when
people like their hands are low you no
no no you can't fight like this no one
fights like this he's got stop the take
down you're always around boxing right
you can do this in boxing there's no
takedowns or kicks in MMA no one in the
world fights like this there's not one
person not PE Diaz do this where they're
here but they're traditional boxers no
when everyone's like God these hands are
low because you've got to worry about
again it's the old old school way of
thinking hands are low no it's mixed
martial arts the Reigns are different
you can have your hands low right when
you're engaging you need to have your
hands up and stuff like that
but um what I liked is that he's a
purple belt and Jiu-Jitsu but it was
able to not panic and C he stood up when
Jac Ray Jac Ray at one point had him on
his back he had his back yeah I mean
crazy stood up I was wrong man Robert
wicker is the ne he's the next truth
middleweight division good luck like
beating that guy after dismantling
jock I like UFC like here fight
contract unbelievable enjoy that son get
to the [__] back of the line ain't
that incredible that's life that's and
now so you got the the problem is though
Whitaker is a little bit of a not he's
in a great spot career-wise but you know
he's not going to fight for the title
right now because bisbing and GSP are
fighting so that holds that up word on
street is they're fighting in July from
what I hear if GSP pass
Medicals so
that just ties that up so then Whitaker
fights maybe rockold or Yol
Romero um
yeah well no actually I think it feels
like he would fight it feels like yeah
that's who he feels like would be next
in line because M well masasi is number
four well no soua was three so you're
right he beat three and Souza beat wide
or soua beat musasi you're right why
would he go back in Step a guy that
already beat him I think the fight is
rockold um Whitaker right now I think I
don't think Whitaker's W earned a title
shot yet no I'm not saying he has I'm
saying he's going to fight either Yol
Romero who's not fighting for a title
everyone's waiting I think either fights
Yol Romero or or rockold right I think
rockold already called him out too if
I'm if I'm y Romero let me ask you this
if I'm y Romero and tell me if he's
allow able to do this I'm I'm saying I'm
waiting I'm waiting for for you know who
I mean I you know I want that belt why
would I fight a killer like whiter
doesn't work like that though does it
are you not allow can you refuse and
wait if you're you're you can but you're
not guaranteed a Top Shot because let's
say rockold fights Whitaker and in 30
seconds head kicks Whitaker or if
Whitaker goes in there and throws a
nasty upcut knocks Rock cold out in 30
seconds he's getting a title shot over
because he's more marketable he fought
recently Goa rockold if rockold goes in
and dismantles him it's probably rockold
Rock's dying
going to Leap Frog y just cuz he's not
marketable that's true that's how the
game works and and remember Y and jock
Ray had it you know that was a close
fight I thought jock Ray won but they
gave to Y all Whitaker [__] merked
jock it wasn't even a contest really it
was a [__] beat down unbelievable and
I gotta be honest and I know I'm jumping
on the train I don't give a [__] I'm I'm
jumping on the whiter train I think he
beats yel right now yeah with his heavy
hands and taked down defense if he beat
Jacare Su that way he there's no reason
he couldn't beat's face yes there's no
reason he couldn't beat yel that way it
just you know first of all you got to
also remember that yoel is 38 39 uh and
and this is a young 26-year-old who has
26y old speed he's also faster I think
you have to he's faster he hits harder
he has momentum right now incredible
skill I thought and I said this on Big
Brown breakdown I thought stylistically
jock Ray was the worst matchup possible
I said he does great out of any of the
top six jock Ray just matchup wise isn't
great for him and he dismantled him I
stick by it I I think he can beat anyone
in the world in the top four the other
thing is he very loose really relaxed he
looked like he was just you saw fight
against Brunson where Brunson ran chin
first and it was a dangerous fight and
he's relaxed stays composed didn't eat
shots and knocked them out yeah this kid
is this the real deal man where does
Gard musasi uh factor in all of this as
far he's not fact right now because he
has to resign his contract they signed
jock gray you know to eight fight deal
which he'll retire in the UFC now so um
you know he'll never touch belor or
anything like that with mousasi they
have to negotiate his contract and he's
all about money so unless they pay him
the right money I don't think he cares
about titles and stuff like that he's
been there done that yeah he'll walk
over to Bellator who he has a
relationship with Scott Coker right so
we'll see but everybody everybody wants
to be the UFC champ that's the one thing
that Bellator doesn't have going for it
everybody wants to be the UFC champ
everyone wants to have money wow as a as
a guy who with over 50 fights that's
it's not the same you know he he he's
been champ he's Strike Force dream all
this stuff he's been there yeah for a
guy like that you know this is his last
run you know whether he has five fights
left or 10 fights left this is it it's
funny you have to make money you have to
make money it's all about who's who's
going to set me up financially for the
rest of my life whether it's UFC
Bellator Invicta who gives a [__] Joanna
man style you gotta get paid Mone yeah
yeah now um and then then you have
Michelle Waters rose that was a that was
not a good fight it was my fight of the
night not a good fight
yeah Michelle just you know she just got
a little bit outclass on the ground she
didn't offer her much she had that great
that that great headlock that she threw
and then Rose got back rose grappling
you know Rose grappling is just freaking
on another level I would imagine Rose is
has her sights on fighting Yanna again
and this time they've never fought yeah
they have Yanna and Rose I thought you
got no no no you want I thought you want
to beat Rose down no she fought the girl
who's going to fight oh right she fought
the other girl who up yeah she's never
fought Yanna but Dan said Rose is
getting the next title
shot both of those Rose to me and and
Michelle Whitaker are the hottest
Michelle Waton Waton I mean are the
hottest Michelle watt whatever are the
hottest uh fighters to step in the
Octagon very cool man I think they're
very cute um very cool um I think uh
that's tough match up for Rose yo Yan is
just on another level it's going to be
hard to take her down and striking so so
Elite yeah I like the matchup though and
they could use you know Rose as their
Champion if it were to work out and then
uh [__] Mighty Mouse man beat the
[__] out of that dude he's impossible to
and then submitted him so what does he
do now yep uh he's gonna fight one more
time just to beat the record for most
defended and then I think jump to weight
classes yeah and how do you think he
does at 35 good he he's fought there
before yeah but there you know I it it
doesn't make sense for him to fight Cody
garant because Cody's only a one-time
champ right so why would you put you
know one of the if some people regard
him as the best ever which I thought
about this long hard last night Rogan
and I were texting he goes best ever man
now he's the best ever I thought God I
might have to finally agree with him on
this I've always said Jon Jones but with
all of Jon's outside of the Octagon [__]
and and Demetrius you know John's been
gone for how long beating and beating
and beating John's also gone distance
and had very close fights with like you
know definitely with uh yeah g and where
you've never seen that really with I
mean not in the past three years you
haven't seen no we have Tim Elliot his
last fight he almost lost got wobbled
and Tim had his back and Tim's you know
not a Tim's not a world beer he's gonna
be but just at the time he wasn't he was
The Ultimate Fighter winner so we've
seen Demetrius in some trouble and he's
lost before like legit lost to pick it
stuff like that so yeah but as of now I
would rank you know I'm always sizes
when it comes to that I would rank
Demetrius Johnson number
one I do think though that there there
is that that X Factor like you always
talk about where you can't make it you
can't make mistakes like you can I agree
I know that's usually why I always have
you have to put that bring that into you
have I know but I think because John's
been gone for so long he's such a [__]
up outside you can't be my number one
guy anymore so me but no so for me for
me I I always been Anderson you know cuz
he was dealing in a weight class where
it was your margin for error was very
small and well John's is higher than his
for sure see Anderson's not my top two
really really I got GSP and Anderson for
me all over Jon Jones and Mighty Mouse
yes because Jon Jones hasn't fought as
much as as many times so as far as
greatest ever um and you know what I
have Mighty Mouse and Jon Jones the GSP
and Anna Silva after that I don't I
don't like GS not not GSP I don't like
Anderson Silva and Jon Jones anymore in
that talk because they both popped for
they they both they both popped yeah
that's that's what kind of K like you
have to take that in
consideration DJ for sure yeah DJ's
number one now he has a clear record
he's beat all comers and then he beat a
guy like Reyes up you know with an armar
who's a world class Jiu-Jitsu guy world
champion and he's dominating him
yeah yeah look and he's been doing it a
lot longer you know and he'll be it'll
be the most consecutive title defense of
all time after this next one so he's
gonna do that one more and then move on
but it's interesting because Cody has
his fight with TJ even if he beats TJ
which is a tough task if he beats TJ
then he's only a two-time defending
champ I guess Mighty Mouse could do that
but just to get the belt to be a two-e
champ that's what he needs to do all
right get the record there but Dana goes
oh I would just have him keep fighting
for that there and just make it so far
Out Of Reach and then if another guy
another weight class defends it a bunch
then you can do a super fight but for
Mighty Mouse like yeah keep doing that
and you get your guaranteed 375 Grand or
whatever the [__] you're making or you
can do super fights and get on
pay-per-view and make Bank you're
already regard as if not the best one of
the top two best of all time in in
everyone's books I don't know what's
their for
yeah because the money's not and then
and then you and then
you know Mighty mous I even heard in a
uh interview he was saying he's like I
don't know what I got to do to be on
people's pound-for-pound best of all
time he's like hit ladies you know test
positive like he's right and he's like
I'm also sick of arguing with people how
I'm not a draw he's like what do you
want me to do man yeah that's so tough
but the fights were good fights were
really good what did you think of the
stoppage was it an issue for you at all
yeah I thought about that um I think it
was on the side of premature stoppages
but you know when you're the ref and
you're watching a guy's eyes roll back
and you see him turn you know in there
usually yeah you're better to air on the
side of caution especially when you're
deal with the guy Whitaker hit so hard
and jock gr had nothing for him he
turned his back his head was exposed his
good I problem with that now if it was
if it was back and forth it was like a
close fight then I'm like oh God let it
go on just so it's more clear a fight
like that let jock R fight another day I
don't have an issue with it I agree at
all at all then our boy Roy Nelson lost
again he's had a tough go how old is Roy
39 38 I'm going to guess 38 again I mean
you get to that won three out of his
last seven or eight but he's fighting
the best of the best yeah making a good
payday too 40 he just turned 40 wow
that's well I didn't think it was
40 I thought he was 39 or 38 that's
awesome but he's had a great career man
but I don't
you know how many how many he's going to
keep losing he's he's always GNA be a
draw though he's always that guy but
that's how this game
goes
yep there's some good boxing coming is
there a fight that you're is is so no
word on khabib nurov and Tony Ferguson
back on no okay I think there was a
rumor that September I think there was a
rumor nothing confirmed though for sure
I think they're trying to figure out the
July stuff and
then is there a fight you're really
looking forward
to uh just in general what are you
laughing at chin just one of the videos
that kabib Naga made of and the tiramisu
controversy yeah
hilarious hilarious but
yeah um fights only for I mean that that
makeart steepe JDS there there's a bunch
of fun fights coming up man even this
Saturday's Nashville car is pretty good
the main event's kind of [__] but I'll
always watch K Swanson but how about
Nashville the UFC in Nashville this
Saturday we're in Nashville on Wednesday
night and then we dip out yeah then we
dip out I know got Nashville then we got
I'm excited about this Austin Moon Tower
Comedy Festival I think you're going to
have a blast I want to get excited about
it you're going to have a blast trust me
it's so fun to be around just a bunch of
comics you you'll love it is D out there
or no I don't know hopefully I wish she
was yeah that's the funest Yi and deia
yeah hopefully he's out there it'd be
fun though Austin of course on it all
our boys and Austin yeah and then
Nashville got some spots for us in
Austin yeah yeah I'm in Austin all the
time sir I got some spots for us yeah
it'd be fun and trust me you'll love it
I don't want to say it on air because I
don't want people coming it's my priv
place yeah I've been atin I love Austin
yeah it's just out there well not just
but it's out there we'll be eating good
food and drinking good coffee yeah they
have great our day center around we on
the road we're like where's good coffee
usually yeah where's and then usually
usually J sha finds it the best the best
at finding all that stuff it' be fun
best organizer you have some current
events Jen sure did I [__] up your
current events did you have Casey
Anthony on there or that piece of [__]
killing innocent people the piece of
[__] had that but yeah that's good that
we already covered that one all right
the first one is the fade of the Furious
the new Fast and Furious movie wow it
became the biggest movie worldwide of
all time damn did you know that I didn't
know that did you also know that um Vin
Diesel owns the franchise I didn't know
that either but I did hear he made $100
million did you know they say in the
next I think two years cuz they have two
more coming out he might be the richest
man in Hollywood how the because he
because a long time ago he bought this
damn godamn hey man I need to make a
$100 million you're not been diesel
anyways I do too but he
uh I I'm I'm not even hating on it
either I I don't like like action movies
I try to get away from all that [__] but
um I just can't get the fast INF furious
and I was talking about one I was
talking to Jay the other day I went I
was down for the other two and he loves
them and I go but they lost me on Tokyo
Drift he goes that's the best one
brother yeah he's like that's the best
one you [__] I how did they go from
being you know like rice like [__]
race car drivers as kids Rockets yeah I
almost said rice Rockets sorry Chen into
[__] they're working for the CIA
jumping out of planes and the Rocks
coming out of Submarine like how did
they how do you jump to this Jay's like
this is and then goes on this whole
story he knows all the characters then
he said basically cuz Vin Diesel's you
know producer Creator a lot of this
stuff he took that world and then
remember triple XX that he was in and
meshed them so that's how you get this
great series now damn I just can't get
people [__] love it though you got
Charlie steron in it who I heard got
paid a million dollars a day to be on
set she's there for good for
her um and how about this little more
gossip for you how about The Rock and
Men diesel hate each other they can't be
on set at the same time they don't like
each other why you notice a lot of the
shots there they're fillings the angles
they're fillings they refuse to be on
set at the same time they can't why
that's weird The Rock seems like such a
great guy and Vin Diesel doesn't seem
like a dick remember a while ago the
rock did this Instagram video of saying
like on set one thing you can't be late
and be a [__] Diva but he didn't give
a
name okay it rhymes with smim bezel cuz
I I I got nothing but love for the rock
I can't believe the rock is the
the originator of that problem I don't
think he's the originator I think V they
say Vin Diesel he's just he's a diva to
work with it's also his [__] so damn is
that weird but they're saying certain
shots I me like there's like they had
they had to do a lot of fillings and you
you you only see them together like once
other than that they're always separate
which they say makes the story a little
weird cuz there's a lot of times they
should be together but they're they
never are they can't stand each other
interesting I can just see the producers
and agents dealing with that problem I'm
not [__] on the the same set as him
and then and and all hell breaks loose
but if you're Vin Diesel you're putting
up with it because the rock brings huge
ratings obviously I would tell you when
when I I was asked I was called and
asked to present Todd Phillips with an
award at the Montreal Film Festival I
mean Comedy Festival for best comedy
directing and uh they called me and it
was very formal and they were very
excited and said Todd Phillips has
recommended you this is after to The
Hangover recommended you and uh we will
provide you with a first class ticket
you'll be staying at the best hotel in
Montreal and uh it'd be it'd be really
amazing Todd would be very honored if
you would do this for him he'd be so
excited and I was like Todd wood of
course I'll do that first class ticket
to freaking the Montreal film Comedy
Festival I get to do standup and I'll
present him with the a w have a
blast uh I'm there you know I I I I see
Todd we're flying first class I'm like
dude you know it's great and he looks at
me and he goes are you doing this I go
he goes I go I'm presenting you with the
award he goes no he goes he looks at me
he goes hey what are you doing I go what
am I doing I'm presenting you with an
award he goes you are and I go yeah I of
course I am I'm that's why I'm flying
here to give you the award I got a
speech and everything he goes oh Jesus
Christ they're so crazy I whatever he
was tying his shoe and he his assistant
comes in and goes hey um you know uh you
got this award uh they want you to
somebody to present it to you who do you
think and Todd apparent was telling he
goes I don't know if Call's uh doing
stand up out there maybe he could do it
I don't know whatever and he just goes
on to do something else that's all he
had to say and it was like the Todd
Fells would be honored it'd be amazing
and people fill in the [__] words for
you man I thought you were going to give
us
a I thought it had to do with them being
no what I was going to say is this I'm
sorry I let me let me bring It full
circle which is that in Hollywood if one
if a star or somebody with power says
one tiny thing it'll set off a chain
reaction like so when Tom Cruz is about
to do a movie I know this Tom Cruz will
say yes to a movie the year before he's
thinking about doing the movie there is
a whole machine getting ready in place
in case he says yes and then when he
says he's not going to do it which is
like just a mind change everything goes
it just crumples down it's it one person
can have can have a ripple effect that's
[__] beyond anything although that
wasn't such a good all right well want
to get that story out it's all good yeah
what else you got chin do wait do you
guys watch him I I watched them a long
time ago do you watch them you saw the
new one I didn't see the new one but you
love them are you crunk for it I think I
should have just sto the last not if
they're making $100 million do shouldn't
have people but my brother says this
might be the best one yet really you got
Clint Eastwood sun in it you got fre it
looked like too much action with our
jumping in the air I need a story man
yeah I need a story I get bored with the
blowing up [__] yeah that does nothing
for me yeah the first one the very very
first one I like the first one it was
back in the days when even all my
friends would do like uh wannabe street
racing our cars so then that was huge
enormous big deal after that no yeah
what else you got brother all right
Berkeley there was protests recently y
this past weekend and uh this this is
like a wellknown or not well-known but
he's a a known supremacist he comes into
this shot as there's like anti-trump and
prot Trump protesters he comes in and
just socks this girl in the face and
then just books it and he's all over
social media now coward he sucked her in
the face and then ran offz he's a [__]
I'll show you the little the video yeah
he's a [__] oh wait does he get jumped
boom Oh hits her and then oh wait these
these uh White supremacists are just
beating the [__] out of people they're
they're all [__] here oh my God
someone's getting ja
up but yeah he just punches her and then
he flees like right here there's a bunch
of people fighting though he's a little
[__] look at
him someone someone's knocked out
getting [__] up yeah she popped up
though it looks like yeah she
did yeah God what a piece of
[__] yeah said Berkeley again too man
Berkeley they just be Berkeley's always
been sort of a hot bed for lots of
protesting kind of like that kind of
hippie on both sides yeah oh plenty of
leftist [__] and plenty of rightest
[__] that's the dude right there
that's the dude little [__] he kind of
looks like know he's a white supremist
though yeah he has like a website that
that talks about white supremacy he's
he's known for this this the website
yeah he punches women in the face he's a
[__] he he me in trouble they get to
hold him in the authorities don't though
yeah which is probably best look at him
though yeah hopefully they get a hold of
him way to go how so brave of you dude
she dreadlock she also popped right up
she sure did she was like what the [__]
was that it was kind of a push punch
wasn't it he was
like poor little guy I mean how can you
get so mad that you punch a woman in the
face Nathan
Deigo yeah please arrest him all right
well probably turn himself as now he's
still on the Run he's currently
unemployed no [__]
yeah living on a family compound oh good
luck in him there though sound looks
like you get tough looks like you get
tricky yeah good get her looks like he
punches [__] in the face and hides
behind daddy my guess is they got some
guns at the ready I have a right to
defend myself I like how the uh leftists
are all wearing gloves douche what else
you got Jim he has a closed fist there
that was definitely a punch oh he's
powering through her face Mark hunt
style yeah what else you got brother all
right that guy sucks here's a terrible
story all right and in Australia again
that's 17-year-old girl was attacked by
a shark while surfing with her
family wow so she was in the water with
her I think her dad was with her her
mother and sister were on on land
watching yeah and then this girl got
attacked on her leg and then eventually
passed away from blood loss yeah do we
know what kind of shark was probably
that bull or tiger probably probably
probably in Australia probably a great
white white pointer a white
pointer so everything in Australia yeah
uhse reported sightings of great white
shars in the area the past week yeah see
that's where I don't go in the water but
you know Surfers don't care you know I'm
sniffing around maybe doing some big
brown breakdowns live in Australia
that's what I hear and uh might do a
cage di sure as [__] ain't swimming in
the water no you're not cuz they're box
jellyfish as well see I don't mind a box
jellyfish die quick they're dangerous
the danger the dangerous but I'm not
swimming that deep no it doesn't matter
you can be you can be in a real shallow
water with the old
the tentacles out see cuz the the old
Wind Blows in the old wind yeah not good
also know aren't they called aren't they
known as the war jellyfishes no that
would be the Portuguese man of war I've
been stung by a Portuguese man of oh no
I'm not got on my legs and by the way it
was out of the water when they say that
they don't really sting that's a huge
lie it's a [__] huge lie oh it got me
good on on the old leggy peggies now
here's the thing um the box jellyfish
put you in shock right quick
hey what would you do if I was
FaceTiming you I'm like yo B Australia's
great yeah would you the i' be like a I
told him not go to Australia you would
cry for sure no you cry for sure yeah I
probably maybe I would you're serial be
like we have to sell the
house no um that's crazy Surfers have
been advised to avoid the area for the
next 48 hours uh so there was a woman
who about 20 years ago was watching her
son swim and and the Great White bit him
in half he was a teenager in half yeah
bit him right in half now that's weird
to deal with isn't it when a shark comes
up and
goes if you're going to go though if
you're going to go though what an epic I
mean teenage is horrible if I'm like 80
though and I like have cancer I'm like
where they at can you chum the waters
while I swim out there to die this Epic
Death well I want it to kill me like a
[__] seal like I want come I don't
even see
it did I ever tell you I was dating slow
motion and then I'm like this
for you're still cognizant but you're
like oh no it takes a it's going to take
my breath away but I'm just going to let
you guys and
go it's been good you're gonna double
thumb up me dude you look why are you
doing it in slow motion that's amazing
because that's what's going to
happen yeah what a way to go though ites
the water it makes it makes CNN for sure
yeah there's a guy who was up in Santa
Cruz surfing and he was your size 6'4
and uh he felt this he goes Seal's
attacking me look this buddy buddy goes
Buddy's just going like that he gets
picked up out of the water and twisted
and he sees a dorsal fin like over there
and he goes oh and he gets thrown the
shark throws him thought he was a seal
he had a bite mark from the top of his
like the base of his skull to the bottom
of his ass that shark bit him and spit
him out and K nope they were [__]
they they swam they surrounded him they
swam him back to the shore he made it he
lived and uh basically went back in the
water about you know a month later he's
a badass but you know what a way to go
though if you're I'd rather go like that
than colon cancer dude this girl yeah
well this girl this girl die [__]
colon can ah boring moving on how's the
bacon gez how'd brenon die D [__] he was
out in Malibu and a [__] great white
man he was barely out there came out of
nowh and then you guys are just telling
these epic stories and it was like goof
and then the years go by like and brenon
was like no he hit in the nose and
another one came straight at him and and
he was
like bring it and then he just went tell
my kids I love him as his things like I
was like and I was like I won't yeah I
was [__] I'm going to be too busy see
I'd rather have that than had he die
[__] car c how about the guy who
doesn't grant you your last wish tell my
children I love them probably won't or
or I'm like Brian I have something
important to say and I do this whole
[__] M and go huh and then it's too
late yeah cuz you'll be older by the
time I die so you like what I'm like I'm
to tell be like this [__] I'm going to
tell the story My I did a a benefit from
my friend who had stage for breast
cancer and she did her set she got up
and started to you know the end and she
started to um kind of talk about how
this has been an amazing experience for
her and she was going to die yeah kind
of giving her send off
and Jamie Masada at the Laugh Factory
didn't really know what's going on but
he was like we have to get the stage
ready and he like started flicking the
lights on and off and then he shot her
mic off then he started and no no in the
middle of her speech he started to play
music like and he didn't real going on
he didn't realize what the hell was
going on and in the middle of her
goodbye speech it basically then the mic
got killed and was like for the best
like out of a movie like The Worst by
the way she's 100% fine and she beat it
so for the best
why the been like yeah and I know I'm
gonna die any day now Tammy I [__]
Carl like leis it's not on there you
know it was a beautiful speech yeah
she's a badass that woman um shout out
too she knows who I'm talking about
she's still kicking on kicking on she
killed it you have another one chin yeah
this is crazy I've never seen this
before I don't know if you guys have but
a motorcyclist was riding along and then
a snake jumped from the road and tried
to attack him I got to see this guar
it's a cobra we can't [__] relax on
the street Thailand you either got that
fat guy trying to shoot you in the face
you got snakes jumping out look at this
let's see if I can Thailand Thailand too
far oh
[__] y whoa dude have you ever seen that
how he just goes like this that thing
belly flopped and definitely got run
over by the camera car and then yeah the
end of the video he's just riding the
motorcycle just didn't even think twice
about it how hungry is that
snake G whiz I'll tell you what gez G
whiz is Right Brian can you imagine
snakes to start going awall on people
yeah Jesus I can't snake well they say
king cobras will hunt you down king
cobras you know when a king cobra hisses
you know what it sounds
like no what do you think it sounds like
does sound like a lion or something a
crying
baby are you sure that's what I've heard
from who s a heard man hey can you bring
up you seen Sak on plane can you bring
up king cobra you seen snakes on playing
with Samuel Jackson have you seen it I
ain't never seen it oh my God and these
terrorists decide put all these the most
dangerous snakes in the world like up on
your carryon and they're driving they
release it but they release all these
talks that make the snake super
aggressive and this lady's like yeah I
can't wait to and then these [__]
snakes
sounds this one yeah well that one says
epic growling
so these are
like yeah that sounds like a [__]
siss hold hey go don't do this one chin
go to the the first one oh go that that
angry king cobra let me hear that
one so we got the king cobra here I'm
more worried about your goddamn short
shorts you get bit he's a professional
but those shorts
aren't hey yeah dude one's most
dangerous snakes do not try this at home
don't let it B
your I'm [__] holding
it yeah and the phone's
ringing mom got a king I'll be late keep
going it says epic grow we're going to
put him on the ground cuz it's getting
pretty angry and it's heavy and this is
actually a baby but it can still kill
you yeah that's a baby beautiful snake
the biggest baby in the world I just
leave the snakes alone hey doesn't sound
like baby it's all good manbe hold on
dude definitely doesn't no the big one
sound like
this that's not
true who told you that I'm going to try
and kiss I read it I'm just put on the
ground gently damn it is right when you
see it on YouTube Why YouTube at least
at least you can watch Rose and Michelle
Whitaker
tonight yeah you're right
buddy the king cobra bro yeah that sound
like a general snake it's all good we'll
just that was the
baby # yeah it's all good theyve never
caught it on table
in real life can you imagine if it did
sound like a baby or like just to entice
you to get in hey come over here any of
you guys want to see something really
epic just YouTube when you get home how
to catch a rabbit using two snakes
that's all I'm gonna say aboriginally
trick what else you got chin all right
Coachella this past weekend a
dude was look like he's G to take over
the world with that brain little Bandit
no he looks like he has a giant brain
the size of a jelly he looks like a
jelly bean so man stole 100 cell phones
at Coachella how do you steal
them I guess I think ouro was saying
people are
just he just got off on got off on it
drunk high no not got off he's probably
trying to get money Brian not jacking
off on the phones selling them yeah [__]
you know how big of a black market
iPhones are you're not jacking off on
the phones but I mean but they can find
you with their navigation some of them
huh but you can uh use Apple app to
locate their missing devices all dos
later LED back to 6 foot to 6' 20050 lb
suspect like there he is at least 20
phones have been reunited with their
phones well my sh is moving with that
guy hey yeah how funny is you can just
track your pH down or se you said your
phone got stolen go and jump in the mic
right here like turn that phone off
[__] well first of all how did
your phone get stolen and was it this
Jelly Bean Head it wasn't him um I used
to work at flywheel and I was the what's
flywheel it's that cycling place they
have it in LA and just like it used to
it started in the east coast and then
now they move over to the West it's like
uh it's pretty much just cycling and
then they have a bar class which is like
a class that just works all your muscles
oh cool and you were the front desk girl
yeah and so it was dead just cuz it was
new to that area and like it was the
middle of the day and so I put my phone
in like a slot by like the desk like
cubby yeah and then I went to go give a
tour cuz anyone that comes in you have
to give them a tour and then so so I
went and gave them a tour and then I
didn't pay attention to my phone I went
to go look for it and it wasn't anywhere
in there and then I went on the Find My
Phone app and I see it moving and every
single time it'll tell me a correct
address it' go to another place so then
I um locked it and I put my best
friend's number like if you find this
phone call his number and I guess he
went to an Apple store and tried to
steal phones from there and then that's
how they caught him and you got your
phone back yeah cuz they asked him and
so they saw it my phone was with him and
they asked he was like this is my
girlfriend's phone like well if it's
your girlfriend's phone why does it say
if found call this number how do you
lock a phone like that that's pretty
cool oh on um the website if you just go
sign you have to you have to enable it
find my phone and all the information
you can I'll show you how it just
completely locks it my thing is he was
going to go to the Apple Store and steal
phones like the demos like he was going
to rip them off the demo you know you
know they obviously think of that like
as soon as you do it the security goes
off he did steal it and then they caught
him damn they caught his ass Jesus
Christ how about at uh where I work at
boxen bur a phone went missing and um
they did find my phone and it was in a
one of the train he's not they fired him
but so a lot of people leave their
phones out right like I leave my phone
out trainer stole your like not mine but
someone else's so people like when work
out put their phones there cuz the box
and if you're doing business like I have
to be around my phone especially these
days I have to check see if I miss call
something so like after I do something I
might do a circuit and then go look at
my phone or I'm listening to music
whatever people put their phones up on
the ring well someone took a phone this
mom was like what the [__] like I need
my phone it's so important they like
don't worry we'll find they do find my
phone it was in the trainer's bag some
trainer's bag that's so embarrassing all
bing bing oh my God he's all oh thought
that was my phone man is there a chance
that he might have thought that nope you
fired you fire excuse me sir pink phone
with giant Hello Kitty all that's you
fir yeah I thought that was my phone the
one the pink phone with the Hello Kitty
on it how funny is it you can track this
[__] down these days Jesus Christ what's
that what's that everything I needed to
learn I learned in kindergarten that
book with that the basic rules are uh
flush wipe don't take what doesn't
belong to you and if you do put it back
basically and keep your
promises that's the
book right on brother don't take what
doesn't belong to you
I don't know I there was a cons common
sense or being a good person that's
basically what a con about the golden
rule book constitutional scholar said
that the rules uh to how we govern our
you know basically our laws are based on
those principles don't take what doesn't
belong to you keep your promises and if
you break those two first rules uh make
amends that's what you have contracts
for you have Courts for good person what
else you got chin all right one more I'm
kind of sick you know what's weird I
love this one I definitely want this one
on there um Coachella is in me cuz a lot
of my friends are going to Coachella and
everyone's so into it I have no desire
to go you go on Instagram it's just
filled with Coachella pictures I've no
have you ever been in I've never had the
desire W I feel like there some [__] you
go to cuz you're into music and stuff
nope have you been our sua no I haven't
obious we've never I mean no all my
friends are G I just have no desire 30
of [__] yeah I'm 50 of [__] yeah no not
for us what else you got Infowars Alex
Jones is a performance artist as Laura
says in divorce hearing The Alex Jones
who told his Legions of info World War
listeners that bogus stories about the
US government being behind the 9/11
attacks and about Hillary Clinton
operating a pedophile ring out of
Washington DC pizza joint is really a
performance artist uh that's his own
lawyer and don't listen to anything he
says wow so so this is interesting
because is it just a play because he's
going for custody of his three children
his wife's going he's insane how the
[__] give him kids his defense is
going no no no it's just for a show he
doesn't really believe that it's all
made's playing a character so but and
chin and I were talking about this sare
is he just doing it so he does lose his
kids or does he is he actually just
bullshitting because if you're if you're
Eddie bra right now you're like oh my
God it's like if you're super into
Christianity find out that Jesus is not
a zombie it's all fake you flip the [__]
out yeah so are the are the Flat Earth
people like holy [__] man or they like
not Alex Jones believes in Flat Earth he
he thinks that's crazy really yes Alex
Jones apolog about pizza gate and he's a
and and he and he thinks flat earthers
are idiots which they are of course but
if this guy is your Messiah this guy is
your savior end all be all and he you
think he speaks the truth and he goes
I'm just doing it to make some news make
some money it's all fake I'm playing a
role wouldn't you be like what the [__]
yeah I would be but I I I what did I say
a long time ago I go you know he's he is
a performer it's a performance man it's
not you can't be that he's either
completely crazy or it's a performance I
mean he makes his living creating
entertainment he pay they say he pays
his XY 46 Grand a year or a month yeah
he makes a lot of money it makes a ton
of money he got a lot of people
listening to him but does it does it
hurt his credibility where he goes ah I
was just [__] around it's just I I
don't believe it I'm just doing to
create some
news um like are the conspiracy theories
like ah God damn it they're jumping off
that boat now I hope so I hope you don't
take you know I hope if if that's the
only source of your information you're
in some trouble but I feel like if
you're that balls deep in Alex Jones He
says you're like I see what you're doing
and he's like no really I literally just
make all this [__] up I'm like sure you
do I got you for the courts am I right
he's like no I don't believe any of it
I'm literally just doing it to pay the
bills like I got you I'll see you on the
other side like I don't think they're
going to buy he's not a stable person
she reply told the court he says he
wants to break Alec Baldwin's neck neck
and he wants JLo to get raped um yeah
but you can't say what he says like
people oh Brian and brenon want to find
the Ohio serial killer and [__] run a
train that's his ex-wife yeah you know
um I I've I think that uh a lot of
people that listen to him are
um he's only 43 I just realized he's
seven years younger than me um but uh a
lot of people I think that listen to him
and our conspiracy theorists will always
be conspiracy theorists because you're
part of a group you're part of a
community people want to be part of
communities uh they also like to be in
the know and they they assume everyone
is lying to them all the time um and and
uh you know that's that's that's not I
just find it fascinating that he's like
nah man I don't believe in this [__] I'm
just doing it for show me too people
like what the [__] man me too my entire
world revolves around what you say and
you stick by it
yep I feel like if you believe him so
much and you know you can say well he's
just doing it so he does lose his
kids um it just bothers me with him
because I think he does a lot of damage
with like when he says the Sandy Hook
elementary school massacre was stage
which is the craziest I've ever heard uh
but you know those parents have been
harassed by his listeners very badly and
continue to be uh even though they show
death certificates and everything else
you know so but but that's what happens
with people like him he's not he's not
in my opinion a very good guy and you
said it brother yeah I see I'm just
curious what his followers believe I we
we both agree he's full of [__] not a
good guy but I think this the more
interesting story is will his followers
are they going to be hurt are they going
to back off is he going to lose
subscriptions that like that's story
they'll find another Alex Jones right I
mean you know what I mean I feel like
Alex more they're just going to chalk it
up as he's just doing that for the court
so he doesn't lose his kids maybe but a
lot of times remember when you're
mainstream like anytime you're a
mainstream source of information which
Alex Jones is dangerously coming close
to just by the fact that he's got that
many listeners you're going to have the
real conspiracy theorists go off onto
something else remember what Ed Bravo
was saying what Ed Bravo was saying
about conspiracy theorists is that they
get mad at each other because what
they'll do is be like bro you giving
this conspiracy tooo much [__] voice
how about my conspiracy bro that's the
real [__] you know they they everybody
has their everybody has their
consp 911 I can't [__] yeah everybody
has their own thing and if you're giving
too much voice that one you're [__]
biased over there bro you need to look
over here is that it Chen that's it I
got to piss so hard do it do
it finally Aaron Hernandez found not
guilty of double
murder uh I don't know enough about this
how the [__] did he get off on double
murder but he's still in prison for life
right he's still on life sentence chin
yeah for the Odin murder [__] man but
they're going to obviously appeal that
one too Dam motherucker might get out
playing ball I don't think theam sign oh
they'd sign like this like that he's
that good of a player but but hold on if
he's acquitted of dou for sure so in
other words he's been acquitted so why
not have him on yeah he's not guilty why
you g why are you gonna hold it against
him the court of law or highest supreme
justice found him innocent right uh wow
so how couldn't you let him play oh
man wow
man wow what the poor families despite
Hernandez prior life sentence which he
got a lifer tattoo on his neck that's
probably not smart yeah especially if
you get out early to look like a
straight [__] um legal experts said
this double myrtle trial still mattered
for him
personally I mean I I just feel like if
you've been indicted for these double
murders and you get off it's like maybe
but there was another murder you also
did another M yeah so I don't have a
bunch of murders where like you well we
we missed you on this one it just leads
me to believe that he couldn't have been
too innocent in that either but I don't
know dude this is this the
one so that Bradley guy who who took uh
who went on trial
uh went against him he shot him he shot
him in the face shot him with the eye he
lost one eye left him for killed that
guy shot that guy that guy okay but he
got he got he didn't the guy didn't
press charges or something on that one
no because he wanted to kill him the
cops like who this he's like don't worry
about I'm going handle it myself because
he was going to go out and kill him but
then a Hernandez got picked up for so he
was hanging with a good group obviously
rough crowd I think they were saying in
this seral killer that the guy that
Alexander Bradley guy he was a star
witness and he was telling the jury that
yeah I I wanted to get back at him
that's why he was testifying like like
[__] stuff yeah so that's one reason
that they kind of threw all this stuff
out damn cuz they realized that their
star witness was was lying about a he
wants to handle himself Jesus which he
ended up helping Aaron Hernandez with
one eye so Aaron Hernandez really let's
be honest he tried to kill one guy and
really probably killed three other guys
that we know about not appar not not
according to our court system sir killed
one guy for sure yeah one guy shot in
the face and the other two had nothing
to do with it says yeah you know there
it is he's a real real peach he's a real
peach human being you got a uh drop a
knowledge for us um it's it's from a
book by Alvin
Hoffler um and it's called um I'm sorry
that hold on hold please hold hold make
noise while I look for it
make noise make noise it's by it's
called rethinking the future and the
question I'll leave you guys with this
is this how teachable are you um one of
the things he says that people in this
ever changing economy and rapidly
changing world had better learn how to
learn unlearn and relearn because if you
get too comfortable in what you're doing
and whatever the job it is chances are
the days of sticking to the same job
until retirement are kind of good gone
you've got to be able to adapt you've
got to learn unlearn and relearn it's
very important so ask yourself that
question how teachable am I um and if
you're not very teachable why what are
you holding on to you're trying to be
right what's going on there's a better
way to do it chances are so that's my my
wisdom of the day and that's what uh
Alvin Toffler would ask you as well re
the future he's a futurist and he's a
smart dude and he can read the future
and he can read the future
Brandon sha we're going to be in uh as
you guys are listening to this we're
going to start our walk we're actually
walking to Nashville as you guys are
listening this we'll be in Nashville
there's less than 20 tickets left at
zany in Nashville for Tat K live and
then uh we're in Austin for the moon
tower Comedy Festival and those tickets
are sold out Austin Texas anything need
tfatk.com Cal tell them where you're
going to be comedy mix Vancouver May
four five and six you come see me you
bastards and I will be in my let's see
my April 27th show sold out at the
comedy store and then May 3rd I don't
know why I'm having brain uh May 3rd I'm
at the Ice House in Pasadena less than
10 tickets left now tac.com big brown
Breakdown live UFC
21 for the big brown breakdown of the
Ice House Pasadena tatk for anything you
need the clab roots fight big brown
breakdown goes live this Wednesday on
tfatk.com Ro of fight quality softness
with a with a little sprinkle of Brandon
cha sure tk.com Wednesday 5m Pacific get
your tickets now for Brian Ken myself
tatk live
tfatk.com
this is the fin the
kid
we're
out